cette crise pétrolière ça c'était un
moment assez extraordinaire parce que
tout d'un coup on avait des dimanches
sans voiture ont pour les loups les
revendre aux par tout ça c'était le
grand avantage ce spécialement potté
pour l'un jeunes par contre il avait
aussi été des aspects très négatif ça
causait une récession
le prix du pétrole est monté entre a3
flanc par baril à à peupler sifflant par
paris pour les pays d'où je suis c'est
absolument avec l'échappée mais à
l'époque ça a causé un grand problème
économique et c'était la première fois
que les gens ont compris que quand on
dépend complètement de pétrole et en
plus que le pétrole est parti ce pot ni
d'un infiniment il est limité et pour
moi compris un garçon de 10 ans quand
j'ai compris que le pétrole a joué un
lot important
ton avis d'où vient ce pétrole se sont
répondus qui font la photosynthèse
accule lumière sauvage
il prend le co2 de l'atmosphère et l'eau
dont la terre et il produit de la
biomasse et en même temps libre
d'oxygène dans l'atmosphère
cette performance est utilisé comme
comme nourriture par exemple mais une
grande partie de la biomasse fait une
déclaration
une déclaration spontanée et sa ford le
pétrole
cette déclaration émane de ce mot peuple
et une millions fois moins vite que
notre consommation à cause de ça les le
pétrole n'est pas une énergie
renouvelable à partir de lundi vers
l'industrialisation
on a commencé à travailler sur
l'extraction mines et et matériaux et
l'énergie mef appliquer toutes ces
produits a donné aujourd'hui aimait à
l'autre côté on a la pollution est on
allé pêcher même des déchets nucléaires
et on a réalisé que la nature n'arrive
pas à fermer ce cycle on doit faire
quelque chose avec ça et il ya des
conséquences
mais avant que je vous explique les
conséquences et mulets ou aime rappeler
que l'âge de la pierre n'a pas pris fin
pour le constat pénurie des pièges
c'était à cause du développement de la
technologie
les hommes sont était capable a converti
les pièges aux métaux et les métaux sont
tus ont des propriétés favorables pour
gautier tel outil était en jeu devient
sur sa la fin mais un marché mais
continuent avec les défis toujours dit
c'est le changement de climat qui est
partiellement due à notre âme production
de co2
la surpopulation 1-1 croissance
économique qui est passé sur les de
sousse et on sait que les ressources
sont limitées
comment on peut continuer à travailler
sur ces défis 1
une des solutions simples qui est qui
est souvent mentionné sausset il faut
les ti la consommation mais si on se fie
cul là vous voyez là c'est l'énergie par
personne mais le revenu par personne et
on obtient que tout les pays il suivi
cette ligne noualhat il ya des pays
comme la russie et les etats-unis qui
consume deux fois plus pour créer le
même revenu alors se dire on peut être
moins efficace par contre ce qui est
vraiment important dans cette fille qu
il n'y a pas de pays bas personne est
capable applaudir un gros revenus sont
or consommation et à cause de ça on ne
peut pas simplement réduit la
consommation en toi même on monte
augmenter la consommation au futur pour
remonter la prospérité un aigle au
parlement et ça veut dire il faut
installer un cycle fermé un cycle qui
est passé sur les énergies renouvelables
a lancé ici et ap on épluche à 50 ans il
faut produire un peuple et un peuple et
trois forts de notre produit à l'énergie
aujourd'hui est ce qui est le plus
important à cette côté là il faut faire
la cicta ge il faudrait utiliser tout
laisser les montants les déchets des
déchets contient tous les éléments on
ait besoin pour produire des produits et
à courte c'est ça la manière la plus
facile sa 7e qu'il essaierait déchets
pour la production des produits et dans
cette manière on peut aussi produire
beaucoup plus qu'on a aujourd'hui
heureusement mondialement health
énergies renouvelables ils ont un
croissance exponentielle et ça c'était
monter ton 7
cette fille qu la sas et la puissance de
pointe installé pour les différentes
formes de l'énergie renouvelable en
fonction de deux pythons et vous voyez
toutes les toutes les différentes formes
de l'énergie renouvelable
ils aiment ils ont un croissance
exponentielle et la somme de tout et
même plus que exponentielle lt charron
en vain en 2024
la puissance de pointe installé va être
école à la consommation un mondial ça
veut dire 'je ils vont avoir des moments
où on peut tu échappes couvre toute la
consommation d'énergie mondiale avec
l'insi louable dans cinq ans et si on
attend que 50 plus on peut vraiment
complètement couvrir nos besoins
énergétiques et ça c'est quelque chose
qui vient dont son temps j'en sais
quelque chose qui vient tourner prochain
qu'ils sont
notre homme les énergies renouvelables
et intermittents ça sert intégreront les
avantages on a des cycles choux les
nuits des cycles c'est son aile à une
distribution de l'intensité solaire sur
le monde et aussi une distribution de la
vitesse du vent
et encore c'est ça il faut travailler
sur les énergies renouvelables pour le
voulait préparer pour des applications
quels sont les autres applications c'est
simple on utilise l'énergie par la
maison là on utilise à peu près trois
paliers de l'huile l'année chic
correspondent à trois parties de l'île
par an dont les mettre dans la maison
avec une consommation presque constante
par contre pour la mobilité on utilise
beaucoup plus de puissance dont les
voitures on passe à peu près un mois par
année dans la voiture et on consume
aussi un peuple et doit partir de
l'huile dans la voiture si on prend des
mots on arrive même de consommer cette
fois paris redondant un jour j'étais
dans 4 jusqu'au maixent points si on va
respire avec le space château là on
pense une lettre à paris dans une ce
compte et vous voyez la consommation des
pompes au coutelas propres applications
la course ça il faut trouver des
manières pour stocker cette énergie
renouvelable
et si je plante nouveau l'exemple avec
le baril de pétrole qui contient 150 6
litres de pétrole coûte à peu près 136
francs aujourd'hui si je remplace ça
avec les parties de batterie de voiture
il faut 1250 patrick voiture pour
remplacer c'est un pari de petro
ils font un peu p 30 tonnes et coûte 300
mille francs
ça veut dire qu'on doit ps que construit
un deuxième maison jusque pour stocker
l'énergie qu'on attend une un pari de
pétrole une autre option ça c'est peu
lotito dit aux chaînes avec les énergies
renouvelables et là il faut seulement
que l'on 3 kg de l'hydrogène pour y
stocker cette énergie qu'on attend c'est
un pari de pétrole le désavantage de
l'ito changer le plomb en volume et noyé
ici ça c'est un pas long de 13 mètres de
diamètre ça c'est aussi à peu près la
taille de la maison mais on travaille
beaucoup sur des tours méthode pour
stocker rideau chaîne est ici vous voyez
l'absorption de l'ito chaîne ton intime
et olic
il ya des gens qui courait qui appelle
ça un caillou mais ça c'est une pièce
métallique qui à la pause les pompent
l'eau piété il peut absorber commun est
proche l'îlot chaîne les deux chaînes
autre effet une expansion de ses se
mettant et à cause de ça le métal et du
saas castan en poutre lido chaîne du
typhus vite dans ses méthodes
une diffuse à peu près à la même vitesse
que l'eau qui pète diffusant des
spaghettis met le paquet ils sont en
ville que mm encore ce sens et fera
contre à peu près dix minutes
là les particules sont seulement 50
micromètres la course à sa place on
notait ce compte propre surprise aux
chaînes et à la fin on arrive aux
chaînes avec une intensité qui est
repeuplé là tout le temps cité de
l'hydrogène liquide
ça veut dire c'est énorme et mons il ya
un tel avantage en trois séances portées
aussi le métal et encore ça c'est cette
manière
stocker l'hydrogène est lourd pour la
pour l'application stationner ça c'est
pas un problème mais pour la mobilité
ça c'est bien sûr un désavantage et
wyeth ont cette figure à cette intensité
énergétique par volume
les lotos sites énergétiques
gravimétrique pour le pétrole après on a
le poids l'alcool et lassitude
le sivu métallique et finalement tout on
pas ici les batteries et nos
applications il était terminée page
l'at on cite un échec ça veut dire avec
rich and fitch peut aller à l'espace
avec le pétrole et que les scènes je
peux voler pour tout le monde je peux
rouler en voiture de la plus que 1000 km
mais cette check social un tout petit
peu maintenant
mais si je tire is that once it
énergétique peu importe que la moitié ça
veut dire je sais tu es là véhicule
apiculture et si je plonge us qu'une
partie de pau j'ai une voiture de golf
ça c'est un peu les cheyrou en travail
et pour la future bien sûr on veut on
peut voler en revanche les compas sachet
c'est possible avec les deux chaînes de
faire voler un avion mais
malheureusement sont en cash
elles sont passées chez sur le monde
pilote peut encore être ton avion et à
cause de ça il faut une manière de
stocker l'énergie avec une densité comme
la densité un échantillon de pétrole et
on a cette possibilité
on utilise l'énergie renouvelable en
plomb un électricien et aux prolos on a
beaucoup trop sucrés parlement et on
dissocie lola de temps au profit de
l'hydrogène et l'oxygène on laisse aussi
l'option partir à la hausse fin et après
on stocke pas l'idiot chaîne tomber
métaux mais on utilise le co2 de
l'atmosphère ge pour synthétiser de
pétrole et ce à des montages pas peur on
en arrive à une densité énergétique
comparable aux écoles à la densité un
échec était un peu trop facile on
utilise tisséo tout ça c'est une des
ressources qu'on trouve encore plus son
futur il n'y a pas tellement politique
tout le monde reçoit le co2 n'importe
qui produit un sas et c'est un monstre
notre avantage
politiquement et
c'est une technologie qui nous permet
deux temps d'avoir toutes les
applications qu'on a aujourd'hui aussi
on a réalisé sa rep est faible les
balises à sion on a installé un système
d'un autre bâtiment avec tes cellules
photovoltaïques sur le toit ont collecté
l'énergie solaire en protides
électricité a pu noter des partis deux
types de partie pour stocker
l'électricité et avec les et électricité
ont fait un réseau local
on en électrices hausse ici pour le
titre litres chaîne et on stocke les
deux chaînes dont les six tubes
métalliques pas ressasser stationner le
pouvoir un jour aucun autre jusqu aux
mecs sont le poids de cette stockage
laet les tubes métalliques et 250 kg les
batteries qui stocke peu près la même
quantité d'énergie sont cinq ponts se
donne aussi une idée de la différence et
après on prend le co2 et on synthétise
du méthane est du même tonneau et
consorts n'arrête les eaux réaliser tout
ce cycle on dans un système réel qui
produit à partir de l'énergie solaire se
situe au corpus et ça c'est possible
aujourd'hui seront cochet il faut encore
améliorer les différentes composantes
mais c'est quelque chose d'ailleurs
l'exemple est temps les prochains dix
ans on va stocker beaucoup d'énergie
dans cette manière-là
j'aime les finir avec twh de l'énergie
fossile ne prendrait pas fin pour cause
de pénurie de pétrole mais parce qu on a
des maisons par la technologie pour
stocker l'énergie renouvelable et le
nouvel an chinois ou indiens moins cher
que les chiffres oscillent et en cause
du sang on va utiliser
merci beaucoup pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]